défi
communiste communisants
vérité
d'hommes semblables niveau
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous écoutez
scopeo l'observatoire politique je suis
luca cofondateur de scopeo et je vous
souhaite aujourd'hui la bienvenue sur
notre chaîne pour l'épisode numéro 17 de
l'entrevue politique aujourd'hui nous
poursuivons notre série d'entretiens
avec monsieur raphaël emsellem analyste
en politiques publiques qui écrit à
l'occasion dans des médias comme le
point où les échos au programme
d'aujourd'hui nous aborderons l'épineuse
question des libertés publiques qui
apparaissent actuellement menacées voire
malmené tout d'abord bonjour à vous
monsieur raphaël amsellem bonjour vous
nous fait le plaisir aujourd'hui de nous
accorder cette entrevue pour discuter de
l'état de nos libertés publiques et plus
généralement de votre vision du
libéralisme politique
vous traitez vous même fréquemment ce
thème dans les médias notamment les
sujets relatifs à la politique sanitaire
et les contraintes exercées sur nos
libertés au caractère parfois
arbitraires exercée par l'action
gouvernementale et présidentielle et au
manque de proportionnalité dans
certaines politiques publiques avant de
démarrer entrevue il entrait dans le vif
du sujet monsieur amsellem je vous
laisse vous présenter brièvement pour
ceux qui nous écoutent
et je n'ai pas rajouté grand chose donc
effectivement je suis analyste en
politiques publiques c'est à dire que
mon rôle en tout cas comme je le conçois
c'est d'essayer de décrypter l'actualité
sous un angle juridique et philosophique
décidiez
dans la mesure du possible de mes
compétences la pertinence d'apporter un
peu de fond dans parfois
le contour de ce qu'il se passe dans
votre pays ce qui se passe en europe et
de comment est-ce que sont menées aussi
les politiques publiques par les
gouvernements quels qu'ils soient et
donc à ce titre effectivement je publie
dans divers médias écrits j'ai eu le
privilège aussi de pouvoir
passer dans certains médias de visée et
j'essaye de défendre c'est en tout cas
mes grands sujets de prédilection le
libéralisme politique et le projet des
libertés publiques qui effectivement été
à thématique majeure de ces derniers
mois si ce n'est de ces dernières années
alors oui justement c'est bien que vous
précisiez que vous êtes un grand
défenseur du libéralisme parce que ce
sera le sujet de ma première question on
va aborder un petit peu de philosophie
politique avant de creuser le sujet des
libertés publiques comment vous
expliquez vous que le libéralisme soit
historiquement philosophiquement nez
plutôt à gauche dans l'échiquier
politique avec le courant
révolutionnaire qui avait pour objectif
de mettre fin à la monarchie et qu'il
apparaît à linverse de nos jours et ce
depuis plusieurs décennies comme un
courant politique et économique propre à
la droite pensons à des personnalités
même d'extrême droite tels que zemmour
ou le pen aujourd'hui qui se font
aujourd'hui les grand défenseur et
protecteur des libertés politiques ce
qui peut paraître assez paradoxal à de
nombreux points de vue
une partie de la réponse se trouve dans
votre question
le libéralisme est né dans un contexte
qui était celui de l'ancien régime et en
ce sens la division politique entre la
gauche et la droite se faisait selon
d'autres déterminons que ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui elle opposée à une époque
donc les révolutionnaires à ce qu'ils
voulaient ni l'ancien régime
et la monarchie est donc effectivement
par opposition à l'absolutisme royal par
opposition à la société de castes qui
existaient qui prévalait à l'époque à la
fois dans le domaine et politiques et
économiques le libéralisme s'est posé à
gauche parce qu'ils s'opposaient
justement à tout l'autre bord que je
viens de décrire et puis au cours de
l'histoire et 8 des d'autres courants
qui sont apparues qui ont modifié cet
échiquier gauche droite damman je pense
que au 19e siècle avec l'apparition de
la société industrielle
et
l'accroissement en tout cas des
inégalités la question de la pauvreté et
de l'apparition afférentes de certains
courants de pensée je pense au marxisme
au socialisme notamment on va avoir
dix ont une évolution dans ce qui va
définir la gauche et la droite en
l'occurrence plus on va avancer au coeur
de dix neuvième siècle plus on va voir
que ceux qui voulaient maintenir
l'ancien régime au final france par
disparaître espace à d'autres doctrines
politiques qui nous font rentrer dans la
paix la modernité je pense que la
première explication qui fait que ce
courant qui est né à gauche aujourd'hui
identifiées à droite c'est d'abord pour
une raison qui est extérieur au
libéralisme et l'évolution du contexte
politique qui prévalait au moment de sa
naissance et qui a évolué par la suite
le deuxième déterminant qui pour le coup
je crois est beaucoup plus interne au
libéralisme
c'est qu'on est passé d'un d'un projet
de défense des droits politiques des
libertés personnelles était le discours
tenu par puis les tenants du libéralisme
politique
est ce que dogville extra extra
on a eu je crois une prévalence du
discours économique qui a gagné du
terrain
et qui dans le contexte du 20e siècle
avec les raies cesse
un communisme qui gagne en popularité
des doctrines socialiste se diffuser
partout en occident eh bien on a eu des
alliances euh disons de circonstance
entre
grande partie de la famille libérale il
faut bien le dire est une partie des
conservateurs qui était très opposé à
l'étatisme au collectivisme qui était
prônée par ces doctrines là et donc je
pense que c'est parce que on a eu 16
cette déviation du libéralisme dans un
aspect économique
jeu on a pu avoir des alliances avec la
droite et ça apprend qu'il est très
exposée notamment dans le livre de serge
audier
le néolibéralisme au pluriel une
archéologie intellectuelle qui a tout un
chapitre consacré justement aux
alliances politiques se feront d'abord
aux états unis puis ensuite en europe
entre les libéraux et la droite
conservatrice je pense que c'est lié
donc d'une part à la fois à ce qui vient
d'être décrit saisir le des alliances de
circonstance et puis aussi par une
évolution doctrinale et je terminerai
sur ça pour
en première partie de réponse à cette
question
liée aussi à quand on a eu faut se
replacer dans le contexte du libéralisme
au 21 siècle dans les années 30 le
libéralisme était absolument décrit et
on a eu une appétence pour ce qui
semblait être les régimes de l'ethnie et
les régimes de fête totalitaire il
s'était à l'époque il faut se rappeler
à la mode mais il y avait vraiment une
attirance politique intellectuel pour
ces régimes qui semblait beaucoup plus
efficace que la démocratie libérale et
donc dans le contexte de la crise de 29
qui va appuyer ce sentiment général
des auteurs vont se réunir pour essayer
de reformuler libéralisme on va avoir
d'abord le colloque le colloque lippmann
et puis ensuite la société du mont
pèlerin je voudrais naissance et tout un
tas d'école libéral au libéralisme
social libéralisme leleu l'école leur
tri chaîne qui va prendre un petit peu
ses bagages et partir dans son coin
et je crois que dans ce contexte là on a
pu observer
une transformation du discours libéral
qui autrefois était beaucoup plus comme
je disais dans les droits politiques et
qui sait peut-être transformer en un
économisme en ce sens que
beaucoup d'auteurs libéraux ont sans
doute considéré dans une approche que je
crois proprement marxienne qui en fait
la structure de l'économie déterminer la
structure politique et la structure de
l'état et qu'en ce sens
certes les droits politiques ont leur
importance mais c'est d'abord le
fonctionnement de l'économie qui la font
qu'il va avoir une importance
primordiale et en ce sens à voir donc ce
retournement du politique à l'économie
ça c'est pour la première partie de
quelles sont les raisons qui pour moi
font que
libéralisme est identifiée a droit
au nom vous avez terminé avec un point
qui me semble très important de dire
pourquoi aujourd'hui on a des
personnalités comme zemmour marine le
pen puis une grande partie de la droite
conservatrice
à droite même réactionnaires qui
notamment durant cette pandémie s'est
beaucoup posé en pause et pardon en
défense défenseurs des libertés
je crois qu'il ya là ils le peuvent
notamment vu la fille de marine le pen
un accueil café chéri c'est ça et je
laime un eric zemmour qui n'a pas hésité
à dire que le qualificatif de libéral ne
le dérangeait pas
et je crois que c'est extrêmement
symptomatique d'un renversement des
valeurs qui s'est opéré durant la crise
des sanitaires ce renversement des
valeurs où tout un tas de personnes qui
historiquement ne font pas partie du
projet des libertés publiques n'ont
jamais été dans cette famille politique
et intellectuelle du libéralisme
politique et qui soudainement se sont
se sont donné le titre de défenseur des
libertés 6 constitue une arnaque dire
que quand vous êtes un eric zemmour que
votre projet politique c'est la
souveraineté nationale dans son sens
absolutisme ces derniers que la nation
et m
la souveraineté politique et qu'elle
peut en ce sens renverser les droits
politiques individuelles
quand vous avez cette idée que dans le
discours de zemmour une dénonciation
doctrinal intellectuelle du libéralisme
l'aféas très nombreuses reprises très
nombreuses déclarations qui vont dans ce
sens d'une dénonciation du libéralisme
qui voient comme le discours
conservateur réactionnaire traditionnel
le libéralisme serait à l'origine de la
décadence des moeurs de la société
l'individualisation de notre société est
donc en ce sens on a eu un retournement
ou tout un tas de personnes qui
historiquement ne font pas partie de la
famille des libertés politiques se sont
retrouvés en défenseur premier ce sont
des gens comme eric zemmour comme marine
le pen ce sont ici les gens comme ils
vont riou folle attendez je veux qu'on
réalise un petit peu
l'arna il ya dans ce cas devant raymond
folle vous défendre la liberté me semble
t il a écrit un livre qui s'appelle de
l'urgence d'être réactionnaire
et qui concernant l'obligation vaccinale
a dit que c'était absolument liberticide
parce que mon corps mon choix depuis
quand ce camp politique
défend le slogan mon corps mon choix
depuis quand des personnalités comme
pierre gentille et qui depuis
lentille est l'occasion d'interviewer il
ya presque dix ans
car gentil à l'époque il était au sein
de la droite populaire qui était le
mouvement thierry mariani et j'allais
pas quitter la droite de la droite de
l'ump des républicains c'est plus
étaient encore dans la structuration des
républicains l'ump ça me semble bien en
tout cas
donc la droite de la droite thierry
mariani qui sait s'en est allé chez
marine le pen et pierre gentillet qui
depuis des années a eu des accointances
tout à fait le droit je leur reproche
pas les accointances avec des
personnalités de venant de la russie
poutinienne
disons que le régime de poutine est pas
connu pour sa défense de l'âme du
pluralisme politique et des libertés
individuelles et qui soudainement nous
explique on est tombés en dictature on
prive les libertés voilà ce sont des
gens qui par tradition politique ne sont
pas défenseurs des libertés c'est cette
incohérence l'acte me semble très
importante dénoncer et concernant encore
perdre un siège je voyais un petit
entretien il ya peu de temps où il était
avec l'institut de la liberté avec
stanislas rigou il rigolé tous les deux
du grand emplacement pardon de dire que
cette logique identitaire encore
l'horizon de droit de le penser mais
cette prévalence de l'identité
collective qui est défendu par ces gens
en aucun cas n'a fait partie à aucun
moment de l'histoire de la grande
famille gibert a et donc je trouve
extrêmement triste qu'on ait eu ce
retournement
durant ces derniers mois où des
personnes ont pour être détaillés de
très longuement sur le pen un eczéma
tarik terra sur comment ces personnes là
qui ont des propositions qui sont
contraires à l'état de droit qui sont
contraires aux libertés personnelles se
sont retrouvés porte-parole soudainement
de la liberté et je pense qu'il faut le
combattre
alors très bien on en a beaucoup parlé
dans cette réponse des personnalités de
droite voire réactionnaire et
conservatrice est ce que une question
subsidiaire il y aurait aujourd'hui des
personnalités qui s'approcherait dans
une baie réalisme authentique et
question secondaire est ce que
aujourd'hui on peut être de gauche et
libéral à la fois
sur la première question
ça peut être la conclusion de
l'introduction d'autres échanges
on a dit qu'on identifiait le beaucoup
le libéralisme à droite
je voudrais faire depuis quand
elle était plutôt la dernière fois que
la droite s'est retrouvé
en défenseur des libertés politiques
et de l'idée qu'il fallait
lutter contre l'arbitraire du pouvoir
quel est le grand combat libéral de la
droite de ces dernières
et c'est que tu n'as pas y en a pas
parce que depuis 2015 notamment on a un
contexte sécuritaire qui fait que le
débat public
s'est vu confronté à des sujets liés au
terrorisme liées aux
os besoin de renforcer les moyens de
l'état en matière régaliennes en ce sens
à droite s'est toujours positionné
depuis ces dernières années dans le
renforcement des dispositifs
sécuritaires dans le renforcement du
code pénal dans le vote de l'état
d'urgence anti terroriste et donc la
droite ne s'est pas illustré depuis très
longtemps dans un quelconque combat
libéral j'en veux pour preuve terminer
ce point que
valérie pécresse dans un entretien à
l'express avec nicolas bouzou comanche
sa première phrase en disant je ne suis
pas libérée
je crois que c'est extrêmement
symptomatique de l'état du rapport entre
la droite et le libéralisme est en ce
sens là je vois pas de personnalités
aujourd'hui qui s'illustre en la matière
en dehors peut-être gaspard koenig mais
disons que ça n'est pas une personnalité
politique de premier plan après que ce
soit une insulte
l'énoncé et il a extrêmement bien rempli
son sa fonction d'intellectuel en tain
de personnalités politiques je me vois
personne est me semble-t-il que les
rares cas on parle d'un attachement
libéral ce sont en réalité des personnes
qui sont beaucoup plus pro business
c'est à dire l'idée que
rôle de l'état c'est d'aider les
entreprises snif pas une idée libérale
le rôle de l'état dans le libéralisme
n'est pas d'aider les entreprises
c'est
d'abord de défendre la concurrence et la
concurrence est un ennemi de
l'entrepreneur
les entrepreneurs stéphane soumier
l'expliqué très bien
kunter
d'économistes de la pensée libérale le
rôle d'un entrepreneur c'est de garder
ses parts de marché et si président en
acquérir toujours plus donc le but
premier d'un entrepreneur ça va être
d'exclure la concurrence et ça va même
être de l'exclure si possible par le
moyen législatif
et en ce sens le libéralisme politique
dénonce depuis
extrêmement longtemps la collusion qui
peut exister entre d'une part les
marchands et d'autre part l'état parce
que les marchands vont essayer de
profiter de la loi pour exclure les
personnes qui
sont disons les outsider du marché adam
smith laver cette expression très claire
doubliez la source du texte mais il dit
méfiez-vous toujours d'une loi qui vient
des marchands toujours parce qu'ils
chercheront à maintenir leur position
donc le libéralisme n'est pas la défense
des entrepreneurs c'est la défense de
l'économie de marché là l'idée de que la
concurrence favorise la prospérité et
favorise
aussi
en tout cas dans les propos des dabistes
qui sont prêts à en parler après mais
aussi une égalisation des rapports de
force
adam smith quand on y pense le marché il
le pensait certes en termes d'efficacité
d'innovation mais il dit d'abord le
marché s'oppose au féodalisme parce que
dans le chai odalys vous avez le rapport
d'un un prince
et d'un sujet
le prince donnera au sujet ce qu'il
souhaite en échange de la stricte
obéissance
de ce dernier au souverain alors que
dans le marché pour que vous puissiez
obtenir dire ce que moi je veux il faut
que vous répondiez aussi à mes intérêts
je pense permis ce petit écart
conceptuel parce que ça me semble
extrêmement important
de préciser que c'est pas parceque vous
proposait de baisser les impôts de
baisser la dépense publique est d'aider
les entrepreneurs vous êtes un libera au
contraire ça peut même être le signe
inverse
sur votre deuxième question du
du rapport à la gauche ou libéralisme
c'est un sujet très complexe parce que
me semble-t-il qu'il faut au préalable
savoir si la liberté politique
est compatible avec la justice sociale
pourquoi cette question la justice
sociale parce que me semble-t-il que
entre toutes les écoles de gauche c'est
un des points communs qui lie tous les
groupes constitués la gauche
et sur 7
sur cette évaluation du rapport entre
liberté justice sociale mais plusieurs
écoles au sein du libéralisme et j'avoue
que pour ma part je n'ai pas fini mes
réflexions
vous avez la position américaine qui
considère que ya pas de justice sociale
sur le plan conceptuel et que quand on
essaye de le mettre en avant dans une
politique publique vous aurez toujours
en fait des groupes qui vont essayer de
se constituer
pour essayer d'attirer le plus de
privilèges de la part de l'état ce n'est
pas totalement faux
buts par exemple du lobbying à terme de
subventions d'entreprise est toujours
d'essayer d'aller voir les tad le combat
qu'elle tourne bonnes raisons de de
financer tel ou tel groupe
vous avez la position rôle sienne qui
est à l' inverse pense essaye de penser
un libéralisme qui prenne en compte la
justice sociale vous avez encore le
point de vue très intéressant de thomas
spain espagne et alberta rien du rhin
étaient phrase extrêmement acerbes
contre contre l'état contre le pouvoir
et thomas spain est pourtant l'un des
penseurs du revenu universel ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que dans un de
ses textes sait très bien que le revenu
universel dans sa conception n'est pas
une charité le but du revenu universel
dans la conception de thomas spain
c'est pas de soutenir les pauvres c'est
de dire que chacun a un droit un droit
opposable aux autres collectivités à
revenu universel
comment ils skient le tir il le tire
notamment parce que quand on remonte au
fondement du droit de propriété on est
passés obligé de passer par un auteur
qui s'appelle john locke et john locke
il dit droit de propriété est un droit
naturel de l'homme du fait que quand je
vais par exemple travailler la terre je
vais l'améliorer et donc j'ai un droit
légitime de me l'approprier seulement
john locke qui pose 2 limite au droit de
propriété et notamment le fait c'est ce
qu'on appelle une des clauses look et n
du droit de propriété damman le fait
qu'on n'a pas le droit de s'approprier à
bien s'il ne reste pas assez aux autres
et en une qualité comparable
et donc ce faisant ils considèrent que
la persistance de la pauvreté
démontre que
on a une appropriation qui est faite par
certains qui enlève à d'autres jeux
qu'on danse ça pense évidemment il
faudrait aller voir dans le texte pour
le détail voilà il tire donc du fait
qu'il ya des limites à la propriété et
qu' il y a un
revenu universel qui ne peut être
allouée à tous et j'ai oublié une
précision importante ce qui légitime ce
point de vue c'est aussi qu'ils
considèrent que la propriété pas la
terre entière à l'origine est une
propriété collective en ce sens quand
quelqu'un s'approprie une parcelle de
terre parce qu'il faut bien et s'est
trouvé un lien entre ce qu'on parlait du
fait qu'on améliore la terre
est donc obligé de se l'approprier parce
qu'il faut bien établir un lien entre la
terre et l'amélioration est bien malgré
tout malgré le fait qu'on améliore on
enlève deux sets la propriété collective
tel morceau de terre et donc en ce sens
il ya un droit pour tous aux revenus de
cette terre et en ce sens qui t'habille
revenus universellement quoi qu'il en
soit l'idée que je veux mettre en avant
ici c'est que vous avez une multitude de
deux écoles de pensée au sein du
libéralisme à titre personnel
d'une part je n'ai pas de de conclusion
définitive parce que ce sont des
réflexions que qui sont en cours et je
revendique le droit à l'errance au fait
combien on n'a pas forcément à avoir
réponse à tout dans l'immédiat et puis
deuxième point
j'aurais tendance à adopter cette vision
à ronen
qui est un constat historique est pas un
principe théorique
un constat historique
que l'avènement
de dispositifs redistributif au sein des
pays occidentaux n'a pas empêché le
développement des libertés personnelles
la liberté de la presse
pensée d'expression d'entreprise et
cetera et cetera et les libertés
politiques en terme de représentation
politique de pouvoir de contre-pouvoir
de textes constitutionnels qui limite
l'action du politique
ces deux éléments les libertés
personnelles et libertés politiques
étant au coeur du libéralisme et donc
partant de ce constat historique que le
développement de principe de dispositifs
redistributif n'a pas contrevenu dans
l'histoire au développement des libertés
personnelles et politiques
j'aurais tendance à dire
que ce n'est peut-être pas une question
aussi essentielle qu'on veut bien le
faire croire donc en ce sens oui je
pense qu'il peut y avoir un espace pour
le
rapprochement entre la gauche et la di
la défense des libertés politiques
mais le fait aujourd'hui
l'espace actuel de la gauche
fait que on a une vision
de l'état qui extrêmement
interventionniste dans la société ou
dans le pays le plus fiscalisé au monde
en veut encore plus fiscalisé
et
en essayant de dire qu'il faut toujours
limiter la liberté dans dans les
échanges commerciaux au nom d'un intérêt
général au nom par exemple de l'écologie
au nom de la solidarité mme à un point
tel que ça contrevient au droit
politique
établie par la
déclaration des droits
alors après c'est entre eux med sur le
libéralisme politique et philosophique
qui ont été essentiels pour aborder la
suite du sujet nous allons maintenant
entrer dans cet épineux épineuse
question pardon de la politique
sanitaire alors on observe de très
nombreuses atteintes on sait tous
légitimes ou non selon les avis sont été
porté à nos libertés fondamentales
depuis maintenant deux ans et
l'apparition que cette pandémie du colis
de 19 on pense bien sûr au confinement
successifs d'abord mais aussi au
couvre-feu à la fermeture de nombreux
lieux collectifs et surtout plus
récemment à l'apparition de ce fameux
pass sanitaire qui est devenu un pass
vaccinale
aujourd'hui ces éléments font partie
intégrante de notre quotidien alors
globalement quelle évaluation peut-on
dresser sur cette période vis-à-vis de
nos libertés publiques est ce que vous à
titre personnel vous craignez une
normalisation de cette atteinte aux
libertés
je pense qu'il faut différencier
deux choses
la première c'est le climat de
déliquescence des libertés publiques qui
a cours en france depuis vingt ou trente
ans
qui à mon sens est extrêmement liée
d'une part à notre régime politique et
constitutionnelle de la vème république
et d'autre part disons à une démission
peut-être de la conscience l'aube et le
collectif de sauvegarde et la liberté il
faut différencier
ce contexte là et sur lequel je pense
qu'on reviendra de la question
spécifique de la pandémie
il ne faudrait pas croire que le projet
des libertés publiques
s'oppose à toute restrictions aux
libertés qu'elle fait de la liberté un
absolu absolument intouchable quand est
ce que il écrit très clairement alors
que c'est un penseur incontournable de
la liberté qu'il y a des temps où il
faut limiter la liberté
et monique canto sperber
qui est une penseur libéral françaises
disent bien que par exemple les libéraux
au début du xxème siècle ont voté
l'obligation vaccinale face à certaines
pompes et
donc la question c savoir pourquoi est
ce que on pourrait
légitimer
telle limitation de liberté et pas telle
autre pourquoi est ce que il faudrait
différencier ce climat de déliquescence
des libertés que nous aborderons de la
question spécifique de la pandémie
eh bien je crois que la réponse elle est
au fond assez simple c'est que la
pandémie est une situation liberticide
la pandémie est une situation
liberticide parce que l empêchent les
gens d'agir librement et dans les pays
qui n'ont pas eu de politique sanitaire
ou plutôt qui ont choisi de laisser
faire ça me perds
on a vu des gens qui ont adopté un
comportement qui corrige et leurs
habitudes par rapport aux dangers du
virus les gens qui au brésil par exemple
ici de ne plus sortir de chez eux de ne
plus aller au travail
donc des situations extrêmement complexe
qui démontre que la pandémie est une
situation de fait liberticide
elle l'est d'autant plus
quand
vous prenez en compte le fait que la
liberté en fait ce n'est pas que la
défense des libertés individuelles
c'est aussi la défense de l'espace
collectif qui permet ces libertés et
pourquoi je précise ça parce que la
pandémie remet en cause cet espace
collectif d'exercice des libertés un
seul exemple pour le prouver c'est que
dans un contexte pandémique du fait que
vous avez un doublement des cas tous les
dix à quinze jours donc une
exponentielle
eh bien vous avez cette situation où les
hôpitaux sont encombrées
si les hôpitaux sont encombrées ce n'est
pas qu'un souci sanitaire c'est pas
qu'un souci de fait que vous ne pouvez
plus soigner des gens alors c'est pas un
souci jean liste c'est aussi un souci de
droits politiques
c'est un souci que vous avez des gens
dont l'intégrité physique est gravement
mise en danger du fait que puisque vous
avez l'encombrement des hôpitaux et bien
vous ne pouvez pas soigné et vous avez
des gens qui vous d'autres maladies
courantes les autres maladies ne se sont
pas arrêtés avec le coronavirus bien des
gens qui voient une perte de chance de
se faire soigner et qui peuvent subir un
dommage irréversible sur leur corps ou
leur état psychologique est donc en ce
sens cela la pandémie implique une
situation où il n'y a pas la liberté
contre la santé il y a des droits
politiques qui s'opposent à d'autres
droits politiques le droit d'aller et
venir d'avoir une social de la vie
économique à celui de l'intégrité
physique et aussi le droit à la santé
qui est un droit reconnu de façon
constitutionnelle en france et donc
c'est une situation qui illustre très
bien ce constat qui est formulée par
raymond aron dans dans un cours qui
donnait son dernier cours au collège de
france
constat qui énonce qu en fait il n'y a
pas contrairement à ce qu'on pense une
liberté
monolithique un ensemble de principes
homogène comme un bloc et qui a en
réalité toujours des libertés qu'ils
sont en confrontation
et que en fait
lorsque vous avez des libertés sont en
confrontation
le projet des libertés publiques
considère que c'est pas une question de
liberté individuelle ou pas liberté
individuelle c'est comment on arbitre
entre ses droits et libertés est
précisément celle là en revanche il ya
eu des défaites
le projet des libertés publiques
donc
légitime quand vous avez des atteintes
aux droits politiques des restrictions
mais elle établit les conditions
qui rendent ces restrictions légitime la
nécessité
en l'occurrence dans la pandémie
j'espère avoir à justifier de pourquoi
ça me semblait légitime
proportionnée
céline dire que en l'état actuel du
droit on ne peut pas lutter contre
telles menaces urgentes et enfin
temporaire et pour établir les trois
critères le projet des libertés
publiques pensent des institutions qui
sont ceux de la démocratie sont celles
pardon de la démocratie libérale l'idée
qu'il y a des contre-pouvoirs qui soit
là pour
confronter la politique du gouvernement
dans le narratif qui l'essayent
d'instaurer pour légitimer telles
restrictions le fait d'avoir un contrôle
juridictionnel et constitutionnelles qui
vérifie on est bien dans le respect du
cadre de l'état de droit et des libertés
personnelles qui sont garanties par nos
textes fondateurs
et juste pour terminer sur ce point un
peu théorique et conceptuel c'est cette
différence que faisais tu obliges il
entre
disait en fait comment est-ce qu'on
définit la liberté
la liberté elle se définit comme étant
le fait que chacun étant doté dans les
termes qui lui dit c'est par les natures
de conditions qui lui permette de
décider par lui-même des jeux propres
choix qu'il faut faire pour sa vie et
bien en partant de ce postulat chacun a
le droit dit il de vivre indépendamment
des autres est de choisir pour lui-même
ce qui est bon pour sa propre dessine et
raymond aron il commente dans son essai
des libertés en disant qu'en fait il ya
une petite subtilité dans cette
définition de tocqueville c'est que il
dit pour tout ce qui regarde à soi
chacun est libre et c'est en ce sens là
que on reconnaît des droits politiques
et chacun mais pour tout ce qui concerne
ce qui ne s'est en dehors de sa propre
destinée précisément on pense les
institutions de la démocratie et contre
pouvoirs qui sont là pour
arbitrer justement entre ses destinées
qui s'ancre au choc
et c'est en sans cela
que le projet des libertés publiques
peut-être divisé d'une part donc en la
défense des libertés individuelles et
d'autre part la pensée de ses
institutions et à défenses de ces
institutions
qui sont là pour décider de façon
collective du devenir de la liberté et
donc c'est sûr de ce deuxième point que
à mon sens on a
on a eu beaucoup de défaillances pendant
la pandémie
parce que on a eu
au fond un effacement de la vie
politique institutionnelle au motif de
la pandémie
on l'a vu d'abord
dans le conseil constitutionnel
qui dès le départ dès le début de cette
pandémie
a énoncé que on pouvait par exemple
suspendre le contrôle constitutionnel de
la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité est un dispositif
extrêmement important des libertés
publiques par lequel n'importe quel
justiciable peut dire que l loi
qui pèsent sur lui dans un procès n'est
pas constitutionnel et demander
vérification de la constitutionnalité de
cette loi est bien le conseil
constitutionnel constitutionnel a dit
que du fait du contexte de la pandémie
eh bien on pouvait suspendre pour je
crois c'était pour six mois si je ne dis
pas de bêtises
il faudrait aller revoir la décision
exact on pouvait suspendre tel
dispositif
c'est le fait qu'on a eu aussi un
parlement qui a été mise de côté
on a eu un parlement qui n'a pas été
consulté à de très nombreuses reprises
ou alors quand il a été consulté s'est
transformé en service après vente du
gouvernement dira que son action n'a pas
consisté à évaluer la bonne
justification la bonne proportionnalité
des mesures qui ont été adoptées mais a
expliqué que tout ce que faisait le
gouvernement était absolument bien qu'il
n'y avait strictement rien n'arrête
aneiro dire et qui a été dans tous les
médias pour nous expliquer qu'il n'y
avait que ces mesures-là qui pouvait
être adoptée est justifié
et enfin je crois que le dernier point
qui me semble
un bon exemple de ça
ce sont des contre-pouvoirs qui au fond
n'ont jamais réellement confronté le
gouvernement dans les mesures qu'il a
adoptée là je pense en particulier
là on a parlé du parlement mais là où
les institutions juridiques
par exemple le conseil d'état qui
quelque part c'est pas de sa faute mais
se basant sur les seules données
gouvernementales
sur l'état de la pandémie a toujours dit
que au vu de ces données est bien les
mesures du gouvernement sont justifiées
et même par exemple sur des mesures
simples comme le port du masque
on a attendu un certain temps avant que
les institutions administratives se
décide à dire que non ça n'était pas
proportionnée d'imposer le masque
partout en extérieur aux vues au fond de
l'ineffable inefficacité établi par les
scientifiques d'une telle mesure pour
lutter contre la pandémie et enfin pour
terminer sur un exemple on a cette
déclaration du
ministre vers ans
qui disait qu'
il ne transmettrait pas été interrogée
sur la question il ne transmettrait pas
les documents discuté dans le conseil de
défense sanitaire
parce que eux ils étaient beaucoup trop
technique pour les parlementaires donc
on a des parlementaires qui sont des
godillots qui n'ont pas les moyens
d'évaluer la politique publique et qui
donc se contentent pour la majorité
d'être un service après-vente du
gouvernement et pour l'opposition
d'être au fond dans le rôle de témoin
et d'essayer d'utiliser des procédures
liées
à tout ce qui est le cheminement
législatif pour essayer de confronter le
gouvernement c'est ce qu'on a vu quand
ils ont par exemple l'opposition a
réussi à repousser les débats à
l'assemblée nationale et pardon juste un
dernier point c'est aussi par exemple le
conseil de défense sanitaire
organe non représentatifs n'a pas de
légitimité à l'élection ou de légitimité
institutionnelle quelconque c'est
pourtant été le lieu de décision
pendant toute la politique sanitaire et
qui en plus a été couvert par un secret
défense
a secret défense c'est là pour se
prémunir d'un ennemi en l'occurrence en
général une armée de pouvoir obtenir des
informations
de la part d'un gouvernement qui prend
des mesures pour lutter contre cette
menace mais en l'occurrence un virus
pourrait y le virus ne sais pas quelles
sont les décisions qui sont prises à son
encontre quel est l'impératif qui a
légitimé d'imposer un secret de défense
sur des décisions qui peut être est il
nécessaire mais qui de fait était
attentatoire aux libertés publiques et
qu'il fallait donc les contrôler et les
partager à l'ensemble et contre-pouvoirs
et donc pour conclure c'est sur cet
aspect institutionnel où on a un
effacement
du débat politique
de la confrontation des points de vue
légitimé par un impératif sanitaire qui
s'impose à tous or je crois que le
corona virus tout en admettant que c'est
une maladie grave ça n'est pas la peste
ou le choléra ou les gens s'effondre
dans la rue dire qu'il n'ya pas une
urgence telle qu'on doit suspendre toute
discussion tout débat et faire des
procédures accélérées et mettre au pas
lent sont des contre-pouvoirs
je voulais rebondir sur sur un point de
votre réponse ce manque de transparence
criant du conseil de défense a notamment
alimenter
les pensées complotistes les plus
extrêmes et on a du mal à comprendre à
concevoir qu'elle
quelle est l'idée que l'objectif de ce
gouvernement à vouloir cacher les
décisions qui prenait dans un contexte
de crise et en plus dans le contexte
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui des
consultations du
maclean's est donc mckinsey qui est un
un
organe de conseil une institution de
conseil américaine dont on ne comprend
pas bien le rôle dans ses processus de
décision au moment des crises ont
je pense que la faute est à imputer à
une architecture constitutionnelle et
politique
qui est extrêmement favorable l'exécutif
au président de la république
qui
concentre l'ensemble de la prise
décisionnel dans les mains d'un pouvoir
qui au fond est extrêmement solitaire
et ce qui à mon avis a
justifi dû au moins du point de vue du
gouvernement l'ensemble de cette opacité
c'est qu'au fond l'impératif sanitaire
justifie tout
que toute personne ou toute institution
qui s'opposent aux décisions qui sont
prises au fond elles ne font que freiner
des
décisions qui sont absolument
nécessaires
et qui sont sans alternative je pense
qu'il ya eu beaucoup cette idée en tout
cas dans la bouche de la majorité que
aucune autre politique n'aurait pu être
mise en place
alors que même si on le pense même si on
est convaincu que les décisions qui ont
été adoptés sont bonnes qui en partie
mon cas puisque pour ma part j'avais
défendu à l'époque le pass annie terre
voire même jeu
lorsqu'on avait cette discussion je
pensais que l'obligation vaccinale en
tout cas pour une partie de la
population était justifiée donc même si
on est convaincu que les décisions qui
sont prises sont le bol
une société politique ne repose pas sur
l'impératif de
l'efficacité elle repose aussi sur le
respect des droits politiques et des
processus
constitutionnel
parlementaire institutionnels afférents
à la sauvegarde de ses droits et
libertés
et donc c'est parce que précisément on a
régime de la vème république qui permet
cet isolement du pouvoir exécutif
qu'à mon sens il ne se sentent pas
obligés de partager quoi que ce soit ils
ne se sentent pas du tout dans le besoin
de
mettre en confrontation les décisions
qu'ils prennent et je pense que c'est ça
qui permet en tout cas pour partie de
comprendre l'attitude qui a été adopté
par le gouvernement durant la crise
alors justement c'est donc vous avez
évoqué ces questions constitutionnelles
et institutionnelles propre à la à la
vème république on constate ces
dernières années depuis bientôt dix ans
que l'état d'urgence est tristement
devenu la norme en france alors tout
d'abord en raison des tragiques
attentats islamistes qui ont frappé
notre pays et en raison plus récemment
de la crise sanitaire que nous avons
largement évoquée à l'instant quelle est
votre position sur ce sujet et selon
vous vous avez répondu à demi-mot est-ce
que c'est cet état d'urgence généralisée
peut être expliquée à cause de la nature
des institutions de la vème république
comment peut-on concevoir que les
décision aussi lourde de conséquence
puisse être prise sans aucune évaluation
et avec bien souvent un contre-pouvoir
inexistant vous avez notamment évoqué le
rôle du parlement qui est bien souvent
mis de côté
je pense qu'il y a plusieurs fois été
expliquent cette situation
on en a abordé une partie mais je pense
que c'est important de revenir dessus
encore une fois le premier point qui me
semble essentielle c'est notre régime
politique
notre régime politique place le
président de la république et l'exécutif
dans une solitude absolue
d'une part parce que nous avons un
régime constitutionnel
qui place
l'exécutif dans une position beaucoup
favorable que le parlement ça s'explique
notamment par l'expérience de la
quatrième république et du
parlementarisme qui était pratiqué à
l'époque et puis aussi par la conception
gaullienne du pouvoir qui veut
extrêmement personnel
d'autre part
nous avons
un régime qui place le parlement dans
une position de redevabilité
vis-à-vis du pouvoir exécutif
raymond aron il expliqué très bien déjà
à son époque et 60
que dans
la vème république
c'est le président la république qui
fait élire les parlementaires donc c'est
le président de la république qui parle
plébiscite
qui l'a via le suffrage universel et par
la composition constitutionnel qui lui
est favorable c'est le président de la
république qui fait confiance aux
parlementaires de telle sorte que les
députés quand ils sont élus
ils ne sont pas redevables devant le
corps politique qui a fait élire mais
devant le président de la république qui
a permis par son visage par sa position
par l'extrême publicité qu'il a reçu
avec l'élection présidentielle et bien
c'est envers lui qu'il faut montrer
respect et déférence non seulement pour
son élection mais aussi pour sa
réélection parce que la réélection des
députés dépend de celle du président de
la république
et je crois que cette situation de
redevabilité elle a été largement
aggravée par la juxtaposition entre
l'élection présidentielle et les
élections législatives ou vraiment on a
cette concomitance entre
l'élection du chef suprême de l'état et
de son armée de députés qui va le
soutenir durant l'ensemble du
quinquennat ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est parce que
nous avons un parlement
qui n'est pas assez puissant pour
confronter le narratif de l'exécutif ont
bien compris que le rôle d'un
gouvernement d'un état ce sera toujours
de limiter les libertés pas toujours
parce qu ils cherchent toujours de plus
de pouvoir même si c'est une règle
indéfectible de l'ensemble des régimes
politiques à travers l'histoire mais
aussi et même souvent par impératifs
d'efficacité
au nom de l'efficacité
en l'occurrence contre le terrorisme eh
bien on va limiter certaines libertés et
donc adopter certains dispositifs
dans un régime de démocratie libérale
soit fonctionnel et bien le parlement
pourrait évaluer la politique du
gouvernement voir si telle ou telle
mesure dans son détail
est justifiée et proportionnée par
rapport à la situation qui s'imposent m
le fait est que sur tout un tas de
sujets le parlement n'a pas les moyens
de l'évaluation de la politique publique
parce qu'il n'a pas les moyens
financiers et parce qu'il n'a pas un
corps administratif qui soient dédiés à
cette tâche il y a les administrateurs
sont là pour assister députés mais c'est
avant tout fonction
administrative et juridique mais un
sujet qui dépasse le seul cadre
raymond aron il prend cet exemple il dit
à parlementaire ne peut pas confronté le
gouvernement ou le ministre de la
défense sur l'adoption de houle achats
de tels systèmes
de
l'armement sur telle stratégie
militaire parce que le parlement est un
amateur ils n'ont pas les moyens
institutionnels d'être assez puissant et
la solution à ça je crois ce serait
qu'au fond on puisse à 6 le parlement
d'experts parce que le ministre lui
aussi en fait c'est un cetain il n'est
pas spécialisé sur la question toutes
les questions le politiques publiques
sur lesquelles il est amené à se
positionner le fait est que le ministre
en revanche à une armée de conseillers
et une armée liée au fait qu'il est le
chef de son administration
et donc il a des informations et données
qui lui sont beaucoup plus facilement
accessibles si le parlement pouvait
aussi être assisté d'experts je pense
que le parlement pour être beaucoup plus
confrontés l'exécutif sur l'ensemble des
questions politiques publiques et donc
ça implique d'une part peut-être que la
cour des comptes puissent
avoir une place beaucoup plus importante
qu'elle a actuellement parce que
constitutionnellement elle est déjà doit
déjà assisté le parlement mais je pense
qu'il faudrait aller plus loin que
l'état actuel du droit et puis des
moyens financiers quand maman une
institution propre avec de l'argent ils
soient massivement investi
donc d'autre part il ya cette question
donc du parlement et enfin on a aussi
cette question
constitutionnelle
qui est que aujourd'hui le conseil
constitutionnel n'est pas dans une
position où ils arrivent à s'imposer
très souvent le conseil constitutionnel
dit le législateur
est le seul légitime pour estimer si
telle mesure est adoptée et donc nous on
va juste avoir un contrôle de
constitutionnalité assez restreint
et je pense que c'est assez dommage
parce que en réalité
démocratie libérale repose certes sur la
représentation nationale b que la
souveraineté appartient au peuple et
donc par voie démocratique
on décide de certains sujets
collectivement mais elle repose c'est
surtout sur la garantie de droits
politiques précède la collectivité et
sur lequel la collectivité n'a pas de
légitimité à légiférer et sa cellule le
conseil constitutionnel qui par la
constitution par la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen est là
pour justement vérifier la garantie des
lots ouah or il faut se rappeler qu'en
france jusqu'en 1971 le conseil
constitutionnel ne vérifiez pas à la
constitutionnalité d'une loi c'est à
dire que jusqu'en 1971 le gouvernement
le parlement pouvait adopter des lois
contraires à la déclaration au roi de
l'homme et du citoyen
donc ça c'est le premier point
institutionnels et de dire qu'on n'a pas
du tout
une structure liée à l'état de droit qui
permettent
une garantie efficace des libertés
le deuxième point
c'est que au fond nous avons
nous avons perdu perdu je crois l'esprit
des libertés je suis extrêmement surpris
de voir à quel point on est aujourd'hui
capable
au sein de la population je parle en on
est capable au fond d'être dans une
forme de passivité vis-à-vis de tout ce
qui peut être décidée j'étais d'un point
dans un débat et puis on parlait de la
loi sécurité globale loi ont été
filmé des manifestations par drones
d'avoir des caméras individuel sur les
policiers d'accorder plus de pouvoirs
aux policiers municipaux sans penser la
formation qui les rend tout un tas de
dispositifs qui à mon sens du point de
vue des libertés publiques sont
disproportionnées
et quelqu'un m'a répondu
oui mais regardez aujourd'hui dans les
manifestations qui en cours en france il
y a beaucoup de dégradations beaucoup
d'insécurité et donc remettre de la
sécurité c'est garantir la liberté est
donc en ce sens c'est à la conclusion on
peut filmer des gens on peut filmer des
gens même s'ils n'ont rien fait on peut
filmer des gens même s'ils n'ont pas
commis de délit ou de crime ce qui est
un renversement complet de l'état de
droit dans un état de droit
on peut adopter des mesures qui visent à
garantir la sécurité on peut adopter des
dispositifs qui vise à punir pénalement
des gens qui portent atteinte aux droits
aux autres mais on ne le fait pas youri
le citoyen n'est pas d'emblée un suspect
on pourrait même dire que
le fait c'est précisément parce que les
gens sont titulaires de droits
politiques parce qu'on estime dans un
état de droit que tant qu'un individu
n'a pas agi de façon lisible envers
autrui
ce n'est seulement que si elle nuit à
autrui qu'on peut le tenir c'est
précisément du fait de cette conception
qu'on ne filme pas des gens s'ils n'ont
rien à se reprocher
contrairement à l'argument qui consiste
à dire mais puisque vous avez rien à
vous reprocher vous voulez pas qu'on
vous filme donc je pense qu'il y a
d'autre part un abandon
de
de l'esprit des libertés et le troisième
point je crois
c'est que
il y à
une insécurité grandissante dans notre
société du fait de menaces
de menaces sécuritaires réel la question
écologique des crises économiques que
nous traversons et donc il y a un
sentiment de peur et d'inquiétude qui
grandit au sein de la société
et qui donc
cherche
des protections en ce sens que puisqu'il
ya de l'insécurité la liberté n'est pas
prioritaire ce qu'on veut d'abord c'est
de la sécurité c'est des protections ce
sont des barrières qui vont vraiment
empêcher le mal de pouvoir nous
atteindre et d'ailleurs
la bande encore un autre point qui très
bien d'expliquer par françois sureau je
crois aussi c'est parce que nous
n'arrivons plus à tolérer le mal quel
qu'il soit
la liberté implique le masne faut bien
le comprendre ça la liberté à des
risques le risque d'être offensées il le
risque
de propager des fausses nouvelles le
risque que la liberté soit mal employé
qu'est le nice à la fin par porter
atteinte à autrui et donc puisqu'il n'y
a plus de tolérance
par rapport au mal qui peut déboucher de
la liberté sans doute parce
qu'aujourd'hui
il n'y a plus rien qui permet de
supporter ce mal sur le plan théologique
sur le plan philosophique il n'y a plus
rien qui permet de
soulager cette souffrance par rapport au
mal
que les gens veulent absolument
l'éradiquer et l'effacer
et enfin je crois un dernier point qui
me semble-t-il est très important on
sait que nous sommes aujourd'hui non
plus dans le projet des libertés
publiques
mais dans un individualisme
politique c'est à dire l'idée
qu'on se fiche que la liberté des autres
soient atteintes par telle ou telle loi
dès lors
qu'on vit dans l'illusion
de la protection de la jouissance de
chacun dans son quotidien l'idée que je
suis libre bas dès lors que je peux
faire à peu près ce que je veux dans mon
quotidien mais ça n'est pas ça la
liberté politique la liberté politique
cet espace collectif dans lequel on se
préoccupe de la liberté des autres et
françois sureau il donne un très bon
exemple il dit par exemple il a plaidé
auprès du conseil constitutionnel contre
notamment le fait
dans le cadre de l'état d'urgence
par le centre c'est l'état d'urgence
qu'on puisse
sanctionner quelqu'un pour consultation
de sites terroristes
ces lois qui puisait à sanctionner la
consultation dessus de l'hérault prises
sauf cas exceptionnel dans un maquis
administratif ont fait un lifting
et la réaction de beaucoup gens c'est de
dire mais moi je consulte pas des sites
terroristes donc je me fiche que la loi
viennent limiter
ce comportement là comportement qui peut
nous paraître lisible arrêté il ya tout
un tas de raisons qui font qu'on peut
consulter un lycée de terrorisme
notamment pour des raisons
journalistique et de recherche
d'empreintes qui a été exposé par
beaucoup de personnes au moment de
l'adoption de ceux de ce dispositif
sauf que le problème de cette loi c'est
quelle part du principe que
le simple délit de penser
soeurette
nuisibles à la société
que même si vous n'avez commis aucun
acte que vous n'avez émis aucun propos
terrorisme le simple fait d'aller
consulter un psy de terroristes devaient
être réprimés
ce qui en soi peut effectivement ne pas
choquer les gens mais à partir du moment
où on admet qu'il ya un un délit
cognitif quelque part mais en fait on
peut l'étendre à tout un tas d'autres
comportements qu'on peut considérer
comme nuisible et c'est parce que
justement on commence à admettre ces
petits effritement pour les autres qu'au
final le pouvoir d'une façon ou une
autre arrivera à justifier pour nous
même et me semble-t-il qu on le vérifie
du fait qu'à chaque fois qu'on a des
mesures qu'ils sont adoptés pour telle
menace terroriste est bien elles
concernent elles finissent par concerner
d'autres personnes je pense notamment au
fait que quand on a une assignation à
résidence
eh bien on sait très bien aujourd'hui
qu'il ya par exemple des militants
écologistes qui du fait de leurs
activités politiques ont été assignés à
résidence
et ça marche à chaque fois de la même
façon un dispositif d'exception qui
finit par atteindre d'autres personnes
et qui encore plus quand on avance dans
le temps rentrer dans le droit commun
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé avec
l'état d'urgence au risque ça a duré
deux ans deux ans et demi et à la fin on
a
le la mandature actuelle qui insère
certains dispositifs de l'état d'urgence
terroristes au sein de l'état de droit
c'était je ne dis pas de bêtises la loi
sécurité et intérieure
alors là où je conclurai juste c'est que
il y à une faute des gouvernements parce
que les gouvernements cherchent à
restreindre les libertés et soit qu'ils
veulent plus de pouvoir soit par souci
d'efficacité mais c'est aussi notre
faute collective du fait qu'on a perdu
l'esprit de liberté et l'esprit des
libertés politiques qui implique que la
liberté elle n'est pas que la jouissance
individuelle mais la préoccupation
collective des libertés de chacun
merci beaucoup pour ces mots très clair
alors en guise de conclusion en quelques
minutes derrière ce tableau dressé par
vous même qui est un peu sombre pour nos
libertés publiques et pour l'avenir
qu'est ce que vous imaginez pour les
prochaines années en france et en europe
où de manière générale d'un modèle de
démocratie libérale occidentale est ce
que vous craignez la mort de libertés
publiques tout simplement où on pourrait
peut-être être un peu plus nuancé en
disant qu' il y aurait pourquoi pas
l'avènement d'un modèle à la chinoise
qui reposerait sur la sur la
surveillance généralisée sur inquiète
dit social en tout cas sur les libertés
publiques qui seraient de plus en plus
restreinte est ce que vous imaginez que
ce ce modèle-là puisse être implanté en
europe en quelques mots est ce que vous
imaginez que la liberté va toucher à son
terme en europe alors qu'il est né ici
je suis opposé au discours qu'on a eu
pendant la crise sanitaire qui consiste
à dire que des dispositifs qui est
expressément ont été adoptées dans un
contexte spécifique pandémique vont être
prorogée dans le temps par exemple
passer mon père nous a dit mais vous
vous allez voir le passé ni terre va
être adopté
il sera prorogé pour un temps
incertain et au final on n'abandonnera
jamais parce qu'en fait on va le
légitimité pour légitimer pardon pour
d'autres situations si je peux me
permettre sur ce point vous avez dit que
juste avant l'état d'urgence avait été
justifiée pour des mesures d'urgence et
sur un temps donné et qu'il a été
ensuite inclus dans le droit commun je
suis absolument d'accord
je vois un avenir pour la liberté qui
est assez sombre
je ne crois pas dans le développement en
tout cas immédiat de dispositifs
type crédit social chinois parce que
malgré tout on a un cadre démocratique
on a un cadre institutionnel dans lequel
même si le parlement est très affaibli
même si le conseil constitutionnel ne
remplit pas toujours son rôle il existe
existe et face à des mesures qui
aujourd'hui je crois dans l'esprit de
tout le monde absolument aberrante je
pense que personne ne s'aventurerait à
les mettre en oeuvre en france et je
pense il faut différencier à ce titre
les mesures qui sont
à mon sens légitime de contraintes comme
on l'a dit en vue de la protection de
certains droits et libertés en
l'occurrence par exemple le fait de
vacciner les publics notamment fragile
parce que si on ne vaccine passé public
là il y aura un encombrement de
l'hôpital il va porter atteinte aux
droits et libertés
d'autres personnes et en l'occurrence le
pass sanitaires et vaccinales même si on
les taille sont disproportionnées le
principe en tout cas trouve une certaine
justification et au moment où on aura
plus cette justification il le
paraîtront et on le voit non seulement
en israël on leveaux danemark on le voit
en espagne où tous ces dispositifs vont
disparaître parce qu'il ya eu un
contexte légitime d'adoption il faut
différencier ce cadre là je crois du
climat plus générale de délitement des
libertés publiques
j'ai à cette insécurité ce sentiment
d'un 7,5 d'insécurité grandissant et
d'abandon d'esprit des libertés à la
fois par nos gouvernants et à la fois
par les citoyens et l'ensemble de la
population
et en ce sens on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui
n'importe quelle menace ou prétexte sert
à
démanteler l'édifice des droits
politiques
au sens où par exemple quand vous avez
des manifestations qui déborde vous avez
la loi anti casseurs qui met et qui
vient dans l'indifférence générale
essayer d'instaurer le contrôle
individuel d'accès aux manifestations ou
en fait tous les citoyens deviennent
suspects d'être des casseurs et donc le
préfet aurait pu en tout cas dans le
texte original de la loi
empêcher tel ou tel individu de pouvoir
accéder à une manifestation ce qui est
une atteinte totalement inadmissible à
la liberté de manifester
c'est la loi sécurité globale qui du
fait de policiers qui sont agressés va
renforcer le dispositif
pénal et de répression a priori des
comportements individuels et aussi je
crois parce qu'on a ce retournement qui
est à l'oeuvre
ce retournement qui veut que en fait
nos droits politiques sont une
concession
et que du coup on est chacun extrêmement
enclins à les laisser être
entravée et je pense que le retour de la
liberté politique
elle pourra revenir du par si on
constate qu'en fait ce renforcement
perpétuelle de disposer du dispositif
pénal et répressif ne correspond pas ne
tient pas plus tôt à l'épreuve des faits
on constate bien qu'à mesure que nous
adoptons de plus en plus de lois
sécuritaires
on n'a pas un sentiment d'insécurité qui
diminue donc il faut d'abord une prise
de conscience
que la restriction des libertés ne
permet pas d'augmenter l'efficacité en
matière de sécurité et deuxième point je
pense qu'il faut un retournement dans
les moeurs et ça ça ne dépendra pas de
loi ça dépendra pas de politique ça ne
dépendra pas de gouvernement ça dépendra
de penseurs qui soit capable de donner à
la liberté a un sens politique
ils soient capables de réenchanter la
liberté de dire que la liberté en fait
ce ne sont pas que des droits politiques
ce n'est pas que je ne pensais
institutionnel c'est aux fondements de
l'action humaine
si on ne pense pas la liberté aux
fondements de l'action humaine
d'une part ça pose problème sur l'ordre
moral parce que ça signifie que chacun
d'entre nous mais pas responsable de ses
actes qu'il n'y a aucun mérite aucune
dignité à ce que nous faisons et que les
individus n'étant plus libre comme le
dit tocqueville ils sont emportés
dans les flots de l'histoire c'est à
dire l'idée qu' il y aurait derrière les
actions de les individus un grand
principe ou des grands concepts qu'elle
en fait dirige l'ensemble des sociétés
l'ensemble des actions des hommes et au
fond derrière ces grands principes
ces grands déterminant c'est face le
visage de chacun
sefas
la responsabilité qui nous incombe à la
fois vis-à-vis de notre propre destinée
et aussi vis-à-vis de celles des autres
et d'autre part de dire que la liberté
est au fondement de l'ordre politique
que c'est parce que nous estimons que il
y à des citoyens qui ont une part
d'indépendance faire d'autonomie par
rapport à la sphère politique
ils sont en mesure de choisir de choisir
leurs dirigeants
que sans elle celle inverse qui se
produit
c'est non pas les individus libres qui
se choisissent des gouvernants mais les
gouvernants qui parce que les individus
n'ont pas de liberté
peuvent au fond
employés chacun d'entre nous au dessin
au projet politique et électoraliste de
chacun et donc ma conclusion sera la
suivante si on veut le retour de
l'esprit de la liberté ce sera certes
emportant dans le débat public
cette voie de défense des
libertés personnelles de la nécessité
d'un pouvoir qu'ils soient des centres
et - jacobins - présidentialiste mais
aussi un discours littéraire poétique
qui soit capable de réinsuffler liberté
de lui donner un sens politique
peut-être même spirituelles et qui par
là même sera capable
de confronter
l'esprit de morosité qui est en train de
gagner l'ensemble de la société et qui a
bouté sur cette demande perpétuelle de
sécurité
je vous remercie infiniment monsieur
amsellem pour toutes ces versions très
pertinentes sur les thèmes de libertés
publiques et sur plus généralement votre
vision du libéralisme politique merci
d'être un défenseur du libéralisme
aujourd'hui parce que c'est courageux de
votre part et c'est un courant qui petit
à petit c'est face du champ
philosophique en france nous vous pouvez
retrouver en tout cas tous nos
entrevues politique pardon sur notre
chaîne youtube scopeo l'observatoire
politique et retrouver nos différents
contenus sur notre site scopeo point org
monsieur ocm je vous remercie je me
souhaite vraiment une bonne continuation
merci à vous